[Music]
every entrepreneur who's listening right
now knows one thing that I know that
your business is your second child is
your third child is your fourth child I
have no idea how many children everyone
has that's the answer because I'm
treating my business like a parent you
know it's almost like your garden right
those tomatoes are gonna come out that's
you with with the macro I can't control
mother nature just like I can't control
the world but I can maximize my tomatoes
this year if I do good behavior and
that's how I think about my businesses
you got your perspective what interests
you about Sweden and business here a
couple things one you know one of the
great advantages of my life is that I
was born in the former Soviet Union and
so and then my first business which was
a family business
which obviously means I loved it so much
like a child was in the wine business so
the amount of time I spent in France and
Italy Spain so as an American and I
think you know obviously as I moved to
the US when I was three and four like
any place there's things that you like
or don't like about things but obviously
I'm a proud American and have a
especially as an entrepreneur as you can
imagine there's a lot of pride in the
framework of entrepreneurship in America
which is at the top of class on the flip
side one of the things that's a
shortcoming in my opinion of Americans
is they become very insular because
America is such a big part of the world
and they don't travel they don't have
context for a lot of other cultures or
people my circumstances have allowed me
that and so that's amazing
leads me to my answer Sweden which this
is probably my seventh or eighth trip
here because I've done a lot of speaking
here and some business here
in a lot of ways I believe Sweden is a
preview to America in 50 to 75 years
I think the maturity of Europe as a
whole and then specifically in the
Nordics and then specifically to sui
my number one thing that interests me
about Sweden is I kind of think it's I
guess I almost think sometimes that I'm
looking at the place that my
grandchildren are gonna live in if they
decide to stay in America and what I
mean by that is it's obviously an older
country for that point but there's a
there's an incredible thing that Sweden
has that I admire which is socially it's
so outrageously progressive in
comparison to the macro world however
it's not as foofy-foofy or soft or
becomes the cliche you know ideological
thing there's still an incredible level
of practicality innovation
entrepreneurship I guess ultimately I
admire the balance of the business
culture human infrastructure and so yeah
I just
I've always felt you know it's funny I
like to keep things basic I've always
felt good when I was here yeah I mean
listen I I it's interesting question and
I'll tell you why I'm incredibly I'll
use optimistic I'm incredibly optimistic
to where companies can go both on how
they do marketing and communications and
how they treat employees and deploy
culture so though I think that there's a
lot of progressive thinking in the
marketplace I do still think the nature
of a corporate structure and the nature
of being a big cup let's say a big
company still requires you to hit
numbers in every 90 days and so you know
ironically in the bigger businesses call
it the hundred biggest businesses in the
region in this in the country it doesn't
look so so so different than
other parts of the world I think as you
go down the scale I do think that
there's um I think on the coasts of
America on the entrepreneurial level
there is a little bit of a potential for
burnout or too much over working or
working for the sake of working that I
think is a little more balanced here
from the startups that I've interacted
with and so much of the same in the top
hundred companies compared to the CIM
much more to do on culture and people
and marketing and on the entrepreneurial
front a little bit more balance that I
see in other places
well what would people experience that
was different in your leadership do you
think compared to the Suites Swedish
managers are not well known to be hard
yeah they're like more people oriented
yeah you know I actually think that
that's an interesting thing so I'm gonna
you're you're doing something
interesting here which is you're using
the data that you have in the macro so I
think one thing that you'll find
fascinating is somebody who knows a
little bit about my personality online
it was funny I was smiling a little
towards David I would argue that I am
the softest manager at my company and on
the soft I would argue that I am softer
than 95% of the managers in Sweden even
though on the internet I'm an very
outward aggressive American for an
American personality because that's me
as a communicator in content on the
internet the way I manage my people is
very very very different I would argue
that the 43 year old version of me as an
executive has had to work over the last
decade on radical candor and so you know
but on the flip
side what I would tell you is I think I
create at my best and I'd like to think
I'm heading to my best I create very
safe environments if you can get your
employees to feel safe they can be their
best however I do think that some of the
advanced laws in trying to create safety
and balance also creates entitlement and
softness yeah I was following your lead
but I think what we're saying I'm sure
everybody who's listening and by the way
I'm honored to be the first English
guest I care about people's emotions and
happiness and and overall livelihood not
what they produce for me in the short
term as an employee of my company I
don't know what else to say I care more
about I look at our voluntary retention
numbers 10 times more than I look at our
profit margin and I'm I'm an HR driven
CEO not a CFO driven CEO here's why I
want to create clarity for everybody's
listening because I'm playing forever I
own my businesses I'm so for me I can do
things that lead to retention and a real
relationship because I'm not held
accountable to Wall Street or a public
market or a board or I'm so money hungry
that I want to OTT and I believe most
are you because you do have a lot of
people interacting with you how you
scale that personal connection your
ability to see the person the person
that you work with the person
and how can you scale that when you have
thousands of people around so we have a
thousand in our ecosystem at Vayner acts
all the companies I have under
vaynermedia uh I do micro macro micro I
have a very aggressive open-door policy
I mean meaning any single employee that
works for me that requests a meeting
gets a meeting I sometimes when they
don't take me up on that because they're
scared or they don't want to bother me
I'm aggressive in creating meetings with
people to check in so I love people you
know it's why I did well on social
because that was a scaled version of it
and it's why I do well right now with
the five of us and so I'm very
aggressive with one-on-one meetings very
and that's micro and then macro I follow
a stunning amount of my employees on
social media
I read the slack channels to watch what
they're talking about for everybody
who's listening
yeah I mean though I actually think it's
just like email in the end to your point
it was built to be a better version of
email and gchat the problem is no tool
even a good one like slack can stop
humans from being wildly inefficient I
care and have the intent and believe in
the value of knowing them as human
beings to do what I think is my
requirement which is to put them in the
best position to succeed
I apologize I'm gonna give you an
anecdote I was in the London office
yesterday I forced somebody to leave the
media team and now work in project
management a very junior employee she's
been with us for 18 24 months I from the
tippy-top all the way down to the London
office on the micro media team demanded
as a dictator to move her from media to
project management on two things one she
was not having a good relationship with
her managers
and it was neither of their faults after
I investigated personally and - through
the series of her communicating with me
I thought that she had tremendous
organizational skills and I saw her
yesterday and she was so happy I'm a CEO
who happens to also have tens of
millions of followers on social media
does public speaking and here for things
like this I'm stretching credibly thin
and yet I was able to execute against
that and this is not me saying it for
everybody who's listening to think I'm
good it speaks to intent either let me
save everybody a lot of time on this
incredible mission that this podcast is
on either accompany is about its people
or a company is about money any company
that is publicly traded or has a board
that has control over the CEO she or he
has to pander to something outside of
their employees independence whether in
the micro or a massive scale at least
gives you the chance to be employee
centric well it was in the conversations
I was having to her about her not being
happy and then also double-checking and
hearing from her managers that maybe
it's her fault was data I was collecting
and then I came over the top with HR and
Finance and just requested the move so I
didn't even communicate to her that I
was doing the move it just happened
she I when I saw her I'm not sure she
knows how much or how little I had to do
with it and I'm not really in the
business of getting stars on my shirt
but I'm really happy about it and
whether it works out or not I have no
idea but the moral of the story for
everybody one more time especially if
you're listening right now and you have
the power you know something I said
yesterday to the London office was
everything at vaynermedia is my fault
there's a thousand things wrong right
now there's eight 280 people that are
response
before that but at the end of the day I
hired and empowered those eight to 80 if
you are lucky enough to have control and
you're listening right now and if you're
listening to this you care about the
things that we care about
please look yourself in the mirror and
realize you're the one that has the
ability to make the change that you
ideologically believe in that's what I
mean
I mean if if our if we if the snacks in
the kitchen stink if we lost a client if
the micro production team in the LA
office is not working well in the end
every single thing in the company is my
fault because I have the power to hire
and fire every human that is actually
creating that truth yeah I think I think
I could be micromanaging in the
philosophy but you know I think if you
speak to anybody who's been a direct
report of mine over the last decade the
biggest argument an issue they have is
I'm not involved enough I am in the
bat-phone business what that means since
I'm using a Batman reference and I'm not
sure how big Batman is in Sweden or now
that we're going global in the podcast
I'm in the business of being in
responding to so I have no interest in
micromanaging until there's an issue at
hand and so yes somebody could say that
philosophically but an actual
practitioner ship or operational the way
this you know energy that I'm speaking
about manifests in reality is you're
only putting your finger in the hole
that is biggest in your boat at that
moment which means there's a lot of boat
left for those people to run so just to
to give us more
you as the leader when you have those
one-on-one conversations your doors open
someone's coming to talk about it a
challenge or an idea if we could
describe how do you prefer to use that
time how do you empower people what
would how do you spend that time with
them and some of our five minutes just
for clarity for everybody um I don't
have a preference and I don't think it's
my place to have a preference on how
it's spent I have a preference that it
happens because it creates context of a
relationship with me and an employee
which begins the process of creating a
safe environment to allow us to have
actual conversations so by the nature of
the framework it's already happening as
far as how it's spent
you would be fascinated people use it to
vent people use it to actually have
change be made people use it to tell me
something they've always wanted to tell
me I don't really have a preference my
preference is that when they leave and
they go home and they tell their best
friend or their spouse and if they ask
how'd it go with Gary today I know
you're meeting with him my preference is
that it's a positive reaction that they
don't feel that I my number what the
only thing I don't want to happen is
that they say ah he just does that to
check the box it was a waste of time
there of course I'm in the business of
providing value for the people that work
for me so I don't have a preference of
how they want to use it even if it's
just a check-in - you know I had one
recently with a ploy that's been with us
for seven years and she's been crushing
it and we hadn't talked in maybe two and
a half years and it was just it was I
think she just needed to feel for five
minutes that I did have my hands and
everything aka I don't have my hands and
anything but I'm aware of quite a bit if
not most things and her hearing that
where I could speak to detail on things
that she started talking about gave her
confidence that she still works for an
organization that has a CEO that has
care and intent and isn't living in an
ivory tower and
naked with no clothes and that is my
agenda at all times because you as a
person cannot scale infinitely you have
other managers of course I'm just
thinking how can you can talk about how
you foster early in a relationship that
engages both employees and customers
because I see this being outside of the
company walls you you this is the style
your company has towards customers as
well seeing them as people we foster
that kind of leadership by holding
people accountable that have clout in
doing the same yes yes it is imperative
that the 50 most senior people in my
company have somewhere between an eighty
to ninety nine percent of this in their
soul as well I can't ask them to be a
hundred percent of the same intent that
I have as much as possible and then it
is my job back to the earlier statement
of everything's your fault when you have
control it's my job to make the tough
decision when somebody no longer is
allowed to be in our company when they
don't embody that mission managers who
are very engaged in their job but who do
not manage to be engaging visibly their
colleagues because that do happen that
we're not living for their work but they
can't handle their colleagues if it's
detriment if it's a neutral I try to
make them work out if it's a detriment
to the other employees they can no
longer be there I value how the other
boys and girls feel about you over
anything else over the skill over how
much money you bring into the
organization over how great and
passionate you are about your craft if
you are the most passionate about your
craft but the 23 people that are
surrounding you are miserable
because you're a curmudgeon or worse not
a nice person it won't work out if
you're neutral and there are those
leaders I have leaders in my
organization who are great at their
craft who are indifferent and neutral as
leaders when things than the macro are
good it's no problem it's when things
are tough where you need wartime
generals so for me right now because
things in the macro is so good those
executives can continue to navigate and
you try to build moats around them you
try to build them up you try to figure
out if it's a personality trait or if
it's something they've never been
trained on and but but if it's
detrimental to the way you framed up the
question there's there's just there's no
person that is more valuable than the
culture at hand we need more innovation
we need to speed up the rate of change
in the world what kind of leadership
change freedom this is my actual issue
with Europe actually that one of the
reasons innovation is difficult is heavy
handing restrictions this is where an
American business point of view of
deregulation and openness I think goes
too far because people are actually
money greedy but in real life having
more freedom to do things matters how do
you speed up things less rules how do
you speed up things less process how do
you speed up things less fear you know
so you know this is something that has
been my calling card for 20 years and it
is out of it is out of complete and
utter lack of fear complete and utter
disdain for process that is in the mix
for the sake of process obviously some
process is needed and this is ultimately
was the first reason I got into culture
bee
having good DNA about liking people it
was that I understood that if people
were motivated and excited that great
things would happen versus fearful and
political the type of leader that will
create this is one that really focuses
on those three things that I just
mentioned because it's not something we
often talk about we don't look about
safety because we think it hinders
change you know it's funny again I'm
David Dirac who films me and post
produces a lot of my content and has
been on my team for a long time and for
clarity everybody I put out a lot of
content I'm actually starting to wonder
I actually may be and this is a funny
statement especially if you don't know
who I am you might find this audacious
so I apologize but I'm actually quite
proud of this I don't know if it's true
but I think it might be Idol edge Italy
might be the human being that puts out
the most daily content at scale on the
entire internet I I'm putting out 40 50
60 pieces of meaningful content on
LinkedIn Facebook Twitter today
nonetheless where am I going with this
most of this is organized through one
text thread with 30 people on it I have
30 people now who are on my team that
produce garyvee content right strategy
media creative there was something that
was post I mean there there's been
multiple things posted recently because
we have a lot of junior members that
were onboarding to do things where the
junior member the most junior member and
maja want to make sure you're paying
attention is because I don't have this
call your inner cousin I know you're on
the list too now no my boss maja
literally this thirty person thread and
I saw one of the most junior people
posted a podcast that hadn't been edited
yet and had sensitive information and
was comfortable enough to post in the
entire thread hey G my bad now here's
what's important and I want everybody
listen very carefully most junior person
pretty big mistake like in the scheme of
like in
in real life but in the business world
says it in front of everybody and says
it to me and it wasn't a fun thing to
deal with a couple things one that's
creating a world where there isn't fear
thank you but but I have goosebumps and
I'll tell you why I have goosebumps and
this is very exciting for me to say in
Sweden and in the Nordics and in Europe
and in the world there was also a 1% to
5% energy behind the text of a little
bit of fear or let me say in a different
world because I don't actually think it
was fear but I'm trying to make a point
here there was accountability there hee
hee because it's the truth
knows that I might have texted him off
chained and fired him and that I could
do that and that yeah and oh by the way
because the laws don't require me to
give him six months I mean this is
important because because and I'll tell
you why
because I think Europe is so close and
it's just a couple tweaks I don't think
the US has it right
I don't think Europe has a right and by
the way this is my personal way that I
want to run my world I'm not saying I'm
right I'm trying to bring value here for
people to make their own decisions and
it's not it's a nerve based on it's not
that I'm a softy I established early I
really am like if my CFO was here he's
like we don't fire fast enough it
creates entitlement but the fact that it
could happen
creates accountability it is not a nerve
and so it's safety with responsibility
yeah it's just like it it's it's that
the rules don't overly protect you from
from lack of execution or ability so
nonetheless I appreciate you jumping on
this because it is probably the thing
I'm most it's a little phrase it is one
of the things I'm very proud of and one
of the things that I want to talk a lot
more about over the next thirty years of
my life
which is I create very very safe
environments which I now believe leads
to incredibly good behavior for the
people that play within that framework
and by the way I actually believe that
that has to do with a lot of the best
because we're using that theme here in
this call obviously I think that has a
lot to do with some of the best nations
in the world to you know you know as an
American citizen I've traveled the world
my whole life
sometimes in not the greatest places and
I've never been fearful because I know
that those places know that they can't
kidnap me actually running my own
businesses as if they were my children
themselves thus having to ask deeper
questions than just financial success I
just have one more thing I know you want
to move on because I'm getting a little
long-winded here but I'm excited because
I love this subject matter when every
entrepreneur who's listening right now
knows one thing that I know that your
business is your second child is your
third child is your fourth child I have
no idea how many children everyone has
that's the answer because I'm treating
my business like a parent yeah but but
even more like a parent and I'll tell
you why what a spouse or a partner
that's a lateral relationship where is a
child or a business you're in charge of
it you're grooming it you know it's
almost like your garden right those
tomatoes are gonna come out that's you
with with the macro I can't control
mother nature just like I can't control
the world but I can maximize my tomatoes
this year if I do good behavior and
that's how I think about my businesses
in weeks
in I do not like negativity and so in my
early years since I started running
companies right from the beginning my
historic vulnerability that I continued
to work on and as far great in a better
place than it used to be is in my
unbelievable disdain for confrontation
and negativity
I wasn't can Duras enough and would
surprise people when I would fire them
and also created a level of entitlement
which usually led to the firing because
they weren't getting negative feedback
they were just getting positive
reinforcement and and they became
delusional no and unfortunately it
wasn't that suddenly something happened
for the last three years they've always
been bad at these three things I just
don't focus on negatives I focus on
positives they don't hear anything about
it and then they get called into the
meeting probably thinking they were
about to get a raise because four weeks
ago I gave him a high-five about
something they do do well and then I'm
like hey Jan hey Rick you know we're
gonna have to talk about you not being
here and they would be flabbergasted and
I would defend my actions to myself in
my 20s and early 30s on their delusional
how did they not know couldn't they tell
but but a lot of people don't deploy the
self-awareness that I was gifted with
it's not you know and and more
importantly employees always have other
side like everybody there's always two
sides to a story so over the last three
or four years and I'll tell you that my
brother AJ who was 22 years old when he
became my partner of vaynermedia ten
years ago he is far you know he's a good
balance my dad is over critical and only
focused on the negative so I think I
naturally was over positive but then
being in the same company with him and a
father-son I almost had to be a hundred
percent positive to offset a hundred
percent negative and that's the truth
didn't want to be I hate that it's that
I'm smiley because I hate that it yes I
was a little dishonest and a lot to
Sunnis I would not fully articulate my
thoughts to my employees the I would try
to grow so much that it could hide all
their shortcomings but then inevitably
as my companies grew you know it's one
thing when you have a family liquor
store business and you have ten
employees you can manage all of them
when I started getting to eighty and a
hundred net business other people had to
manage and that's when my
vulnerabilities exposed themselves
because I didn't recognize what I was
actually doing and now at Vayner with a
thousand it's become even bigger because
even the quality let's call it what it
is the executives at vaynermedia are a
different quality than a stock boy in a
liquor store when they're 19 at a liquor
store
so I've learned a lot my I've learned a
lot my brother started that process
because I admired his level of candor
even as a kid because it's a natural
skill for him and then and then five or
four years ago Vayner was getting big
we're at four or five hundred people I
was carrying so much of the financial
and emotional burden back to
micromanaging in the macro that I could
see because I'm a practical operator
that there was a financial vulnerability
that if I wasn't going to get more out
of the top fifty people that all
trickled I also didn't like the way our
company was being structured towards
going towards the world I saw which is a
bigger impact around the volume of
creative needed to be put out so we for
the first time after going from 30 to
400 people in three years we did a 35
person layoff the company lost its mind
the overreaction the stuff that I and if
you've been listening carefully the
stuff that I like to take subtle digs
about I so admire your up but there's
subtle things I dig about ironically I
was being hypocritical I was doing the
same thing in my four walls probably why
I've always loved these places because
I'm probably as a as a human I'm
probably way more Sweden than I am
Soviet Russia or even a man
so it's interesting that was a really
important moment of my career because a
couple things one I'm gonna talk
tomorrow about entitlement and I'm gonna
put pressure on the parents in a room
saying look if you've been paying for
everything for your kid and then at 22
you tell them you're cut off
they're not prepared and then they're
gonna be mad at you and we look as
Outsiders being mad at the kid you
entitled brat you you you think you're
entitled to two thousand dollars a month
allowance from your parents but but
you've trained them to not be capable
that's what I did
at Vayner and it was a painful year on
our culture and it's been a big big
teaching moment for me a hundred percent
because it surprised me when you say I
use the word dishonest which was not
fair which should have used the word non
authentic because you say that you love
meeting people you say you don't build
relationship I do and I think what it is
that kind of the fuel for that process
it's so you're taking away an ingredient
in that relationship it was by not being
completely honest 100% now what you can
imagine though is the recipient of that
lack of authenticity enjoyed the [ __ ]
out of it because it's just positive
reinforcement instead of critical
feedback so both parties were quite
happy for the majority of that
relationship it was only when I had to
deal with the realities of the merit of
running an organization that has
consequences that I even had to address
it yeah it's it's it's not my favorite
part as you can imagine one of the
reasons I have such a big audience in
the world is I can be a hundred percent
authentic with them because I can't
analyze the truth after I engage with
them because they move on to their lives
and I'm not sitting there living unlike
vaynermedia where after I tell Carol
that she's the sweetest sweetheart of
all time that her strategy work is
incredible right that she's a sunshine
in the office that she's always
responsible and hardworking and she
leaves meanwhile I know that clients
aren't happy with her or
she's incapable of upselling a client
which is becoming detrimental to the
business you know you're right and and
so what's really fun about being a human
being especially one that's probably
gifted with a lot of things that do make
them successful is going through the
course of your career and deploying
humility to understanding your own
shortcomings no matter how sweet they
taste for both parties and then
adjusting and I often have said that the
43 year old version of me even though
the 25 year old version of me thought he
was going to be great and thought he was
naturally talented the experience
matters and it's why I value experience
it's great getting older and so I'm
proud of a getting to a place in my life
where I could recognize it and address
it and by the way I'm still not all the
way there
you know if we're calling on a scale of
1 to 10 I used to be a 1 or 2 on this
I'm probably a five to 7.5 on this right
now but I'm on my way to it being an 8
or 9 I'll never be a 10 it's not
naturally in me not only am i proud that
I've been able to move from 0 and 1 to 5
to 7 I'm proud that I'm in a place where
I can articulate it for 10 minutes on a
podcast knowing that it can help
somebody who naturally is in the
juxtaposition similar to where I was you
know in the past I try to create a very
safe environment it's funny we have an
incredible new head of limited
incredible
I'm outrageously optimistic of the
incredible woman I just hired to run the
London office
and yesterday I sat down with her and I
spent 20 minutes just making her feel
safe hey Sarah
you can tell hey Sarah this is literally
verbatim hey Sarah because she has a big
rolodex she's a big get for us she has
her own client base I go look if
somebody reaches out to you tomorrow and
they're like Sarah we want to talk to
you about vaynermedia but do not bring
Gary we don't like his brashness you
need to tell me that doesn't hurt my
feelings I'm thrilled
I that I'm unemotional whatever is the
right interest of the business you don't
need to micromanage me right the truth
about what whatever the hell is in front
of them running an operation is not a
education or philosophical exercise what
do I want I want to know exactly what is
an issue operationally right this second
to you from your perspective and you
running your world and how can I help
the reverse of that coin what can I do
to put you in the best position to
succeed are you looking to talk to me
more often are you talking to me less do
you need fight you need some leeway with
your financial P&L do you need me to
rah-rah the troops do you want me to go
talk to the most senior client because
the client that you work with which is
the second most senior client is giving
you a very difficult time I am in the
ambulance firefighting emergency doctor
bat-phone business I am only built to
act in helping for you to succeed within
this framework and I believe when you
look at our organization the people that
have been with me for seven eight years
the people that are winning the most
really see it and the people that don't
hear it and think it's a thinking they
deploy cynicism that I'm just want to
hear myself speak and it's an ideology
and that I won't actually do it because
what's amazing about employees is how
many in this by the way I'm gonna set
this up on the podcast I'm actually very
excited to say this I actually think for
all the very thoughtful conversation we
just had I can feel it in my body right
now this piece of content may be the
piece that brings the most value I am
blown away by how many employees have
made judgments on their organizations
without trying to address it
the amount of my employees that come
into my office on year three call my
bluff finally to address something I
address it in 48 hours within a month
whatever the issue is they come back and
say I can't believe he did it
and then give me 31 other things that
happened in the first 36 months of their
tenure but they decided to be cynical
they vet with their friends at a beer
they talk about it in the girls bathroom
they tell their mother but they never
told me or the organization it is the
great shortcoming of employees in our
world today my friends call the
company's bluff call the bluff I mean if
you haven't gone to HR or to the CEO or
however your world is structured well
then you have no legs to stand on that
the company stinks
if you have and they haven't delivered
vent away but until you call the bluff
then you're just complaining because you
like to complain let's talk about that
because I understand why you're saying
that you'll appreciate where I'm going
with this I have a lot of empathy for
that person on the other line right now
listening because there's only so much
you can do like like that's just the
truth and people always ask me Gary I
want to impact people the way you do or
change the world
these very heady things I'm like well
just do it for one person it's action
everybody say you know people love to
id8 or pontificate but they don't do and
and so for me if this is a game about
doing so yes be that change but be that
change as somebody who does it within
what they can control you know you
knocking on the door of the CEO and
demanding XYZ is very cute but you're
not sitting with all the context and so
yeah
the engagement podcast can you try and
narrow down what is the number one
driver of engagement in the workplace
the ability to listen the number one
driver of engagement is the macro and
then the individual employees that make
up the company's ability to actually
listen man a gosh really cultivating our
abilities forward for you and your it's
the only thing I think about if you
think about the just to create some
levels of clarity here for everybody the
the emitter the ability to engage and be
engaged in things that nation completely
start with the seed of being heard you
know somebody being heard it is
completely different than somebody who
feels they're not hurt is that true good
that makes me feel good yeah
opportunity or possibility to influence
the outcome situation nothing makes me
more excited than what a junior employee
comes gives a recommendation and then
seven months later it actually becomes
true and they reach out to me and they
never think it was them hey Gary Sarah
Thompson here you know we met seven
months ago
you know just saw the announcement or
just saw this or this just happened you
know I'm sure it wasn't me and you
probably don't remember that I asked you
but I'm so glad it's happening and then
me on a flight at 1:30 in the morning
gear Sarah
it happened because you walked into my
office create where I heard you I
thought you might be right I
investigated we did it that ended it
into that it's one of my favorite parts
of my job any of you are aware of the
which business leaders of the
correlation between employee engagement
and profitability non-existent because
CFOs are too literal an excel sheet and
90% if not 99% are not deploying
emotional intelligence above their
financial intelligence and they are
spreadsheet basics and yes how do we how
do we clarify this correlation because
it shows us that you've seen it others
have seen it research often times and
reporting doesn't penetrate a cliche CFO
you know the no matter what your you and
I cut I comment you know I come and talk
from personal experience somebody else
comes from an academic point of view on
this shows dear CFO the you know you are
wasting four point nine million dollars
a year of people sitting there and and
crying and not working and if you had
better engagement you you know I know
that to be true in my bones in my bones
I know that a proper culture creates a
scenario where people have better output
in the time that they deploy I know that
is intuitive human but if you're but now
let's have some empathy in the other
direction if you're the CFO of Ericsson
and you have to report numbers and you
have the report numbers every 90 days it
gets very hard for you to make the
investment let's play this out okay so
Rick and Susan hear us and they deploy
they're bought in they believe in you
and I what happens next well you have to
start putting in money to put into
programs you have to put in money to put
into human beings that rev up the
culture they all of a sudden we asked a
CFO who's looking every 90 days on a
whim in their mind because it's not
mathematically quantitative all no
matter what our reports show they have
to pour money
in to this for the hope that later it
pays dividends
I've heard people don't invest so should
people real quick shareholders like we
live in a financially driven world in
the business world and in all of that is
all fine to your point I think this is a
financial question to there's just a
word that I left out we live in 2019 in
a short term financial ecosystem startup
founders want to sell their company in
two years to a bigger company
everybody is so impatient to financial
success both in the big companies and
one-off entrepreneurs that people are
not making investment into long term
health of their organizations and the
shareholders don't care either I mean
you know how to change an heart what is
your advice to hey Aisha - hey
engagement who is really trying to put
this question on the agenda of the
executive teams of large organizations
that there is a positive correlation
between high employee engagement
innovation profitability and also just
health numbers number of days sick break
etc so the way I in the in the macro
ball this it's basically what I'm doing
for a living the reason I'm putting out
so much content as a human and
collecting so much popularity is to
deploy it against better behavior both
professionally and personally
in the micro of your question anybody
who's listening right now you will be
100 percent historically correct if you
beat this drum you will be 100%
historically correct that employee
engagement leads to financial rewards I
have no idea where when you hear me say
that
on how convinced you are right now are
you a 90% at 50% my one take on it is
you will be 100% historically correct no
different than the people I'm sure in
the 1950s and 60s who were yelling that
cigarettes were bad for you when that
was still being debated became
historically correct I have no idea if
the 89 year old who was doing that feels
amazing about this and different back I
don't know but that would be my plea
which is if you're like me wired like me
the the ambition to be correct and the
enjoyment of bringing positivity and
practicality to our society and then
being revered and admired for that truth
when it plays out if you're lucky enough
to have that wiring please see it
through and keep beating this drum
because it is you that ultimately makes
those changes any of you who is
responsible for your engagement at work
50/50 and you you're also firm believer
that anybody could build their own
unique business and I've watched a lot
of your podcast and you were number one
piece of advice for succeeding is work
hard how do you manage that with
sustained engagement over time in a
healthy way because my number one
statement is actually be happy I just
need to contain Oh different than when I
realized five years ago that I needed to
do a better job in radical candor I've
realized over the last 10 years you
saying earlier that you weren't being
there was a level of dishonesty made my
stomach go down right and and and but
I'm about to go to the point you right
now saying you're number one a piece of
advice is work hard made my stomach go
down further nope Ellison let me clarify
this I believe in work ethic like
nobody's business
I believe that work ethic is an enormous
variable of success
youjin I and controllable which is
powerful however my you know through the
years what I've not done it as good of a
job though I've sprinkled it though I've
done unique pieces of content about it
though my second book was called the
Thank You economy though in my first
book crush it I speak about this the
reason this is a very easy answer for me
is the way you sustain it is loving it
it doesn't become being a workaholic
when you're doing your hobby the reason
I started telling people that any the
reason I you know when people hear
anybody can do it that I gag Gary this
is the secret you it's I'm like no no
let's take a step back we now live in an
Internet world where the cost of entry
is zero and every one of us who's
listening right now has a passion
whether that's fishing
fashion hair coloring drinking wine
sport I believe that anybody can start
the process of creating content around
something they're passionate about which
will always do better than something
you're not passionate about and that
over time that may lead to something
that can pay you 30 40 80 thousand euros
or dollars a year or eventually millions
if you're ultimately talented are you
willing to live a humble life that makes
47 thousand a year only speaking about
blueberry jam but you're happy is my
pressure and question and so I've to me
it's something that I'm pushing more
clarity around which is I want you to be
happy
I of course well the beauty of
entrepreneurship is without there it's
inherently accountability otherwise it
fails I do want people to be happy and I
actually think accountability leads to
happiness when you think the
government's in charge the the media's
in charge Facebook's in charge this boss
is in charge when you believe somebody
else is in charge of your life you
immediately start the process about
happy
this accountability is the framework of
happiness
it doesn't mean bad things aren't
happening it's not delusion to the macro
and justices of the world
it's called accountability you know what
a great way to wrap this up I'm
struggling not to smile very heavily the
only reason this all matters is
everything else gets commoditized with
technology and what we will be left with
is emotional intelligence and
communication so what do I want my
daughter to be equipped with self-esteem
that doesn't lead to a delusion a
self-awareness radar that allows her to
know what actually makes her happy and
for her to have an incredible work ethic
out of the reality that she found
something she likes so much that she
doesn't even realize she's working that
much that old adage of finding something
you love you never work a day of your
life
is remarkably on point and most people
think it's baloney except for that small
percentage that actually have found what
they're best at and they love the most
because technology yeah and honestly
honestly I think basic income and I
don't know the details on this but if
you're alluding to being subsidized
because technology is taking your job um
this is where I do think in Europe and
this is a u.s. conversation as well that
is where I do get concerned I'll tell
you why farming was what everybody did
200 50 years ago 100 years ago we farmed
everybody and then machines came along
and we didn't need you to pick the corn
the Machine picked the corn we didn't in
nineteen thirty forty fifty sixty say oh
we're so devastated for all the farmers
the farmers found different jobs if we
are now saying
as a society of 7.7 billion hey we're
gonna subsidize a portion of this
transition you're starting to already
create that level of entitlement and
lack of accountability I hear this all
the time Gary
what are we gonna do about all the
drivers driving trucks and cars in the
u.s. is one of the biggest right I go if
you're a driver in the world right now
for the last 36 months the amount of
coverage that we've had that driving is
gonna be obsolete if you're a 27 year
old truck driver right now and you
aren't planning on what you're gonna do
about autonomous cars we have to ask
ourselves where do we hold people
accountable for their actions to adjust
to the realities of the world and not
that I have the right answer because my
answer earlier was employee employee
5050 and maybe what Sweden or Europe is
doing is actually right maybe there does
need to be some small version of
subsidies but we need to be very
thoughtful that we don't put human
beings in a level of entitlement because
as soon as that happens we get into a
world of non action and that becomes a
very difficult place to be finally you
know we're on a mission to raise the
level of engagement in organizations
starting in Sweden and our goal is to
create a global movement if you were the
minister of engagement in the government
what would you focus on so more people
can go to work because they want to and
not because they're forced I would focus
on a heavy investment in modern
communication tactics across 10 to 15
meaningful platforms like YouTube
podcasts Facebook Instagram snapchat on
and on and I would pump information
literal and grey around this subject
matter comes is how you change things
not laws not mandates communication to
change the heart and minds of everyone
so I would pour almost all of my money
into modern communicate
tactics to bring awareness around this
issue itself thank you so much thank you
for joining thank you for that
you